we are back with the fox news alert the
fda giving its first detailed look at
pfizer's kova 19 vaccine
briefing documents just released show
effectiveness after
just one dose supposed to have two
with trials raising no safety concerns
and so far
so good yeah that's great officials say
that the trial data
is consistent with recommendations that
were put forth by the agency for an
emergency use authorization the fda is
expected to decide on whether to
authorize pfizer's vaccine
within days all right so let's bring in
kaley magnandi white house press
secretary in this role right now because
we know at two o'clock today
the white house will be hosting an
operation warp speed vaccine summit
one of the objectives i imagine kaylee
is to get people pumped up
to take the vaccine because if we have
it and people don't take it
it's a problem a recent study showed
just about 6 in 10 americans are ready
to take it
is that a number you can live with look
it needs to be higher than that
this is a vaccine that president trump
got us in record time it usually takes
four to 25 years president trump got it
in just 10 months today
among other names you'll be hearing from
dr peter marks at the fda
this is the man that goes line by line
through thousands of lines of data
to make sure that this is safe and
effective he looks at how it interacts
with every population
here in the united states minority
individuals
older individuals younger he literally
looks at how it comports
with each and every american to ensure
it is safe it is effective
and rest assured moderna and pfizer are
looking like they're just that and we're
hoping for
fda emergency use authorization and
short order well that would be great
because a lot of people want to get it
the big question is how many doses are
going to be available
there's a story i'm sure you've seen in
the new york times in the washington
post as well that apparently
we all know that the government is
signed on for 100 million doses which
would
uh help 50 million people if you have to
get two shots
but the story according to the new york
post or new york times
and the washington post is that in the
summer
pfizer said to the federal government
hey you've already bought 100 million
doses
do you want to get some more because
other countries are queuing up and the
government said no
and now i know we're negotiating to get
more from pfizer
but they've sold it off to other
countries the eu i think bought 200
million
doses and it sounds like according to
the latest reporting
is that we might not get more from
pfizer before
june or july yeah it's just simply not
true that they offered extra doses
according to the people who are involved
in the negotiations
with each and every company we
contracted for a hundred
million doses uh so it's just simply not
the case that we were offered more and
rejected them
so when will we get the next batch look
we will get the next batch in short
order uh those negotiations are ongoing
but
what we're hopeful is steve we have six
vaccines in phase three clinical trial
uh two have approached that 94 95
efficacy
uh but others are on the way and for
this president no other president has
done this obama biden didn't do this for
their bungled swine flu vaccine
president trump negotiated
in advance this is novel what he did to
even have these contracts to manufacture
these doses to have a plan where within
24 hours every zip code in america
will have a vaccine as we go through
those most vulnerable
proteins and that sounds great so you're
saying that we will get
more from pfizer before june or july
absolutely we've contracted for 100
million doses
so we've already negotiated that in
advance and this plan is laid out
ready for distribution and contrary to
the swine flu vaccination bungle
and obama biden we're ready to go kaylee
we had a guy on our show earlier
um his name is jack conde and he's the
president and ceo ceo of the california
restaurant association
and he took it to court because he says
my my folks who own these restaurants in
our association
they can't serve food even outdoors and
so the judge said well i'm going to keep
the ban on outdoor dining for now
but the health experts the leaders in
california are going to have to prove to
me that there's evidence
that you can get covet or people are
getting covered because of these
restaurants
here is jack conde who is uh suing
because he's
so upset about the what's happening with
the restaurants listen
for nine months now we've listened to
our public health officials tell us that
these shutdown
orders are based on um or they're guided
by
evidence and science and um we have an
la health department who's
essentially targeted the restaurant
industry as if we're responsible for the
the latest outbreak in the pandemic when
evidence proves
otherwise and in la county in particular
where you have
outdoor dining is the only lifeline that
they have to get through this
um that has been sort of pulled out from
under them uh by
by a health department that is
essentially is acting on a gut reaction
last time i
last time i looked gut reactions weren't
part of the scientific method
so kaylee now the vice president set up
his task force
um vice president uh president-elect
biden set up his task force for corona
and he's keeping fauci on fauci says
there might be some some evidence that
says it's dangerous it shouldn't sit
outdoors
but then you have the other guy on the
task force admiral girardi saying
there is no evidence what's what is
truthful
here's what's truthful democrats are
anti-science democrats are
anti-constitution
as admiral jois said there is no science
suggesting if you're outside socially
distanced wearing your mask
appropriately that you cannot dine
there never was science showing that
schools should shut down because kids
were super spreaders that didn't exist
president trump said that and here we
are many months later and the science
once again is on our side as it's always
been democrats will shut down your
churches but allow other commercial
establishments to stay open like
governor cuomo who was rebuked
by the supreme court democrats are
anti-science we will always put forward
the science and it is a travesty
what they are doing to small business
owners uh to companies
and to churches across this nation it's
unacceptable we know we watch the
president give a speech on saturday
watch the debates on sunday we know the
vice president's going to be going to
georgia on thursday so that's how much
these senate races mean to him
uh and uh and the party uh kayleigh if
things don't break your way with all
these challenges including pennsylvania
which could end up in the supreme court
have the president do you know if the
president's decided if he'll go to the
inaugural because his reports
he's going to have a major event in
florida at the same time
of the inaugural if he's not in it yeah
the president will announce his plans uh
for january at the appropriate time so i
won't get ahead of him
uh and i'll leave that to him to
announce in the at the right time
you can tell us i wish i could ainsley
all right if you were gonna tell it i
know you would tell ainsley and then she
would tell us
so that's the way it's going to be my
first person of course we've seen it
before
thank you thanks all right